hey everyone my name is googa from
Google foods and these are my favorite
snacks
[Music]
oh
oh first stop this
these are from my childhood it's
basically wafer but since it was made in
Brazil it tastes different now they have
the dark chocolate and also white
chocolate my favorite is always going to
be white chocolate now they're
individually packed in Brazil whenever
we're having like our lunch made usually
they only put three so you're always
craving for more
hmm
wow it's sweet it's also extremely soft
when you're taking a bite not crunchy at
all I was born in nubara miniature is in
Brazil and it is literally the city
where all the cows are that's why I'm
known for steaks this one right here I
actually have it quite regularly with my
children every time we go to a Brazilian
store we can find this one very easily
and it is not only my favorite but also
my kids
oh guarana Brazilian national drink if
you are Brazilian you know what this is
it's made out of a small fruit and it's
just I gotta open it
oh isn't that satisfying
it's slightly sweet not extremely sweet
guarana itself is a fruit so it has a
unique taste so as you know I
collaborate with a lot of creators
nickto Giovanni Joshua Wiseman Uncle
Roger the funny thing is that every time
somebody comes to collaborate with us in
their Studio we have a lot of different
drinks and surprisingly they always grab
the guanana first I was actually
introduced to this one not too long ago
by a friend of mine
yo Nick you tried this in my house last
time you should have let everybody know
that you tried it for me yes everybody
he tried it for me
how'd you find this this is from my
childhood oh wow this is also known but
in Brazil we call Dos Village it's
literally caramel that it's made in a
very specific way it's not thick it's
almost like a paste but a very thin
peanut butter and the way to eat it is
quite interesting as well you take off
the tip like this
they don't have garbage here and as you
see it starts coming out little by
little and then you literally hold it on
your teeth like this
and then you just
it's so good this reminds me of my
childhood in Brazil everyone knows what
this is it's everywhere there but very
difficult to find it here in the U.S
wow I don't know if this is considered
Brazilian or not because it's called
yakuch it is a Japanese sweet probiotic
milk it's delicious and I love Japanese
culture and I'm also love their food I
cook a lot of wagyu steaks because it's
literally the best in the world here in
the US you literally just pop up the
seal make sure you shake it first
oh it's so good it's fermented milk
slightly sweet a little bit Savory and
it has a kick in the back of your tongue
of like
what are you tasting but that's not how
we drink it in Brazil and if you're
Brazilian you know where I'm going
thank you we wanna savor it it's
expensive okay first you shake it grab a
toothpick right in the middle
put it in there and then you just suck
on it
[Music]
it lasts longer and for whatever reason
don't quote me on this
it tastes better if you drink it this
way
here we go now we're talking Brazilian
culture at its best this is called
if you've ever been to Australia or a
Brazilian steakhouse you know what this
is I also have this on my cookbook guga
breaking the barbecue Rule and what it
is is Brazilian cheese bread we eat it
all the time in Brazil for breakfast for
lunch for dinner for snack does not
matter what time it is
it's always good to describe it it has a
nice crust but the inside is kind of
gooey so when you combine both together
it's like the perfect bite these are the
best
and they have two different kinds
not only the shape can be different but
they also make it in different ways this
one is Savory this one is sweet I prefer
the Savory and literally what it is is
made out of Yucca flour and as a child
you don't like this when you go to your
grandma's house she literally forces you
because it's very cheap to make and eat
it but when you become an adult you
crave it it's crunchy it's more for the
texture than the flavor just listen
watching a movie it's ten times better
than popcorn
[Music]
guys thank you so much for watching I
hope you guys enjoy my favorite snack
don't forget to check out my book Google
breaking the barbecue rules and we'll
see you guys on the next one take care
[Music]
thank you